ja ich begrüße alle meine
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer zur
aktuellen sitzung in der wir uns mit der
freiheits theorie karl leonard reinholz
befassen werden
die frage die wir uns stellen welches
team wie reinhold in dieser sehr
komplexen freiheits debatte eines orten
ist und inwiefern er diese debatte voran
bringt wir sind ab und zu schon auf frei
zu sprechen gekommen
ich darf erinnern an eine stelle in
sicht des kreuzer rezensionen wo er
reinhold ausdrücklich recht gibt
hinsichtlich seiner bestimmung des
willens genauer gesagt der willkür ich
nach oben rechts dazu ein blick rein und
ich zeige jetzt mal ein bild wie
reinhold ausgelegt so sei aus und er hat
eine schrift geschrieben verfasst die
briefe über die kantischen philosophie
eine ganze reihe von briefen die er
schon vorher begonnen hatte und aus
diesen briefen lesen wir jetzt einen
brief der sich mit der willensfreiheit
befasst noch ein bisschen was zur
biografie von reinhold er wurde in wien
zunächst bei den jesuiten dann bei den
banner bitten das sind also orden zum
priester ausgebildet
er verließ dann wien und wechselte 1984
ins protestantische faymann sieht
reinhold war sehr flexibel in seinen
lebens bewegungen auch in sein denkt
bewegungen die wir noch sehen werden
er veröffentlichte ab 1786 seine briefe
über die kantischen philosophie in denen
er kann's philosophie einen breiten
publikum verständlich machen wollte
diese briefe waren ein großer erfolg
man kann sagen dass reinhardt überhaupt
erst ganz philosophie unter die geistige
situation die die menschen derzeit
gebracht hat es war sozusagen so eine
art bestseller
man könnte auch sagen
ganz leicht gemacht so ein bisschen ehrt
ihn jetzt nicht simplifiziert aber er
hat ihnen einfachere sprache und nicht
so kompliziert der geistigen generation
seinerzeit auch die jüngeren philosophen
näher gebracht und er wurde dann 1787
professor für philosophie in jena und
wechselte einige jahre später nach kiel
also man sieht von wien nach kiel das
ist nicht der nächste weg und genauso
verhält es sich auch mit seinem denken
er vertrat im laufe seines lebens ganz
verschiedene philosophische position und
systeme deswegen hat man auch rainer und
häufig vorgeworfen er hätte keine
wirklich eigene theorie kein eigenes
system entwickelt wenn man es vergleicht
mit anderen den kann seinerzeit zb
fichte der eigentlich immer wieder am
selben grundgedanken weiter gesponnen
hat dem der subjektivität da ist dann
doch reinhold viel flexibler sagt man
mal
er hat sich am anfang sehr stark mit der
aufklärungs philosophie befasst und dann
ganz stark auch mit dem subjekt begriff
wie fichte also dass ich hat eine
philosophie ohne beinamen verfasst damit
meint er wollte so diese einheit der
philosophie darstellen also nicht
theoretisch und praktisch für diese
philosophie als solche hat dann einen
satz des bewusstseins aufgestellt in
dieser zeit in jena und in kiel hatte
dann eine ganz andere philosophie
vertreter eine art sprachphilosophie
also man sieht er war sehr flexibel und
er hat auch als vermittler eine große
rolle gespielt
ja was können wir noch zu ihm sagen wir
haben einen leitfaden wie fern grenzt
sich reinhold hinsichtlich der
bestimmung des willens und der
willensfreiheit von kant ab eine weitere
frage wie kann man reinholz begriff des
grundvermögens verstehen das sagt dann
immer die freiheit design grundvermögen
eine weitere frage wie bestimmt heute im
griff der willkür
dieser begriff ist schon ein paar mal
aufgetaucht und wir müssen ihnen genau
bestimmen so viel zu diesen fragen und
jetzt gehen dann mitten in die texte
nein wie gesagt aus den briefen die
amerikanische philosophie zweite an
er sagt alle bisherigen philosophen
system und einem metaphysischen begriffe
ohne ausnahme stehen mit richtigen
begriffe von der freiheit im geraten
widerspruch auch die kritik der einen
und der praktischen vernunft von dem
mann erkannt hat diesen begriff nur
angedeutet keineswegs aber mit
denjenigen merkmalen aufgestellt die
seinen gegenstand von allen anderen
unterscheiden sie hat noch keine
erklärung davon geben können weil sie
diese lieber nur erst möglich machen
konnte und musste und im übergang von
dieser nun verhandlungen öffentlich
keine möglichkeit ist durch die meisten
ihr er gehörigen schriften der freunde
der kritischen philosophie viel mehr
erschwert als erleichtert von diesem
zitat finden wir schon so ein paar
wichtige stellen
einerseits geht jetzt hier reinhold auf
die kritik der reinen vernunft ein und
die kritik der praktischen vernunft die
mache oben rechts ein link erst rein zur
kritik der reinen vernunft wo wir es mit
der trans zentralen feier zu tun hatten
und dann war ich oben rechts auf den
linken zu krediten praktischen wo wir es
mit dem thema der praktischen freiheit
zu tun hatten
also das hier ist die transzendentale
freiheit freiheit und das hier ist die
praktische freiheit oder auch moralische
freiheit
so wir sagen also in diesen kritiken
wurde der wille
darum geht es ja um den willens begriff
der wurde da nur oder auch die freiheit
der verträge wurde dort nur angedacht
also nur angedeutet aber nicht richtig
bestimmt genauer gesagt er wurde nicht
erklärt
er sollte nur möglich gemacht wenn
freiheit soll du als denk möglich
ausgewiesen werden
das trifft sicherlich auf die kritik der
reinen vernunft uhr
das ist kein technologie die möglichkeit
der freiheit gibt es auch auf die kritik
der praktischen vernunft zutrifft dass
die frage bekannt jedoch noch stärker
die wirklichkeit der freiheit als ein
faktum der vernunft ins zentrum stellt
ja und diese übergang von der nun
vorhandenen möglichkeiten persönlichkeit
denen möchte reinhold jetzt wirklich
vollziehen und er sagt jetzt die freunde
das ist ein ganz beliebte wenn drei
freunde der kritischen philosophie er
sagt nur freunde der kantischen
philosophie diäten dabei nicht sehr
geholfen also die hätten kann es
ursprünglich ein sich ihr verdunkelt als
dass sie sie klar gemacht hätten wer ist
jetzt dazu zählen mit sicherheit kommt
christian schmid ja das ist der denker
des intelligenten fatalismus und da
mache ich auch hier oben rechts ein link
rein das war diese provokative theorie
fatalismus die theorie dass wir nur in
guten frei sind und böse nicht dadurch
fichte dagegen polemisierte mache ich
auch oben rechts seine kreuze rezension
rein also diese freunde der kritischen
philosophie von der kantischen
philosophie
die haben dabei nicht zählen geholfen so
das ist diese
das ist jetzt diese diagnose ja immer
weiter die den bewusstsein sondern aber
vielleicht eben darum der spekulation
bisher zur fern gelegene unterscheidung
zwischen der unwillkürlichen forderung
und der willkürlichen befriedigung die
beim vor dem stattfindet eröffnet den
weg zu diesen übergang
von der möglichkeit in wirklichkeit den
ich bereits zurückgelegt zu haben glaube
wenn ich mit den wählen als das vermögen
der person denke sich selbst zu wirklich
befriedigen oder nicht befriedigung
einer forderung des begehrens zugestimmt
jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen aufpassen
was meint jetzt hier
reinhold mit der unwillkürlichen
förderung und der willkürlichen
befriedigung
das sind also zwei momente die beim
freien wollen stattfinden man kann hier
noch im freien
hiernach einfügen also es hat immer
etwas unwillkürlich was fordert und es
hat was willkürliches was befriedigt in
der freien entscheidung also wollen beim
effektiven vor und man kann jetzt sagen
wenn wir eine unwillkürliche vorgang
haben dann sehen wir uns konfrontiert
mit etwas zu dem wir uns verhalten ist
also wir haben zb einen trieb hier ja
wie uns regt sich ein trieb oder das
sittengesetz macht sich bemerkbar
also wir haben eine moralische
aufforderung das sind jetzt für reinhold
unwillkürliche forderungen das heißt sie
sind nicht zunächst mal von uns selbst
willentlich hervorgebracht sondern sie
richten sich an uns und wir müssen auf
sie reagieren
man könnte diese unwillkürliche
forderung auch als first oder des
designs bezeichnen nachher frankfurt
oder die letzten jetzt ein erster
ordnung weil jetzt kommt noch die
willkürliche befriedigung zu
das heißt wir können uns jetzt dazu
verhalten von einer zweiten oder zweiter
ebene und zwar wunderschön
also das ist dann die willkürliche die
frei gewählte befriedigung oder nicht
befriedigung oder nicht
befriedigung dieser ohne könig in uns
auftretenden forderungen sei es eine
extreme ist reinhold spricht gar nicht
vom sieben gesetzte spricht vom eigenen
betrieb
das wäre der egoismus oder von
eigennützigen trieb das wäre das sind
eingesetzt
jedenfalls wir müssen uns dazu noch
unerfahren erst dann sind wir frei wenn
wir uns dazu reflexiv erhalten sprich
dem trieben nachgehen dem sittengesetz
folgen oder eben nicht und das ist nach
bayreuth die wirkliche freiheit besser
und damit wird jetzt kein vor oder den
freunden der kantischen philosophie
diese unterscheidung nicht genug
vorgenommen über diese freiheit nichts
als die unabhängigkeit der praktischen
vernunft von einem bestimmungsbuch durch
lust und unlust ist und wer jetzt war
zur freiheit des willens gehört aber
keineswegs die seele allein aus macht
habe ich in den meisten ihrer gehörigen
schriften der freunde der kantischen
philosophie äußerungen angetroffen die
mich nichts anderes vermuten lassen als
dass dieses einzelne merkmale frei von
diesen schriften für die ganze freiheit
gehalten
reinhold kritisiert jetzt dass es eine
freiheit gibt die als die unabhängigkeit
der praktischen vernunft für den
bestimmungen des lustigen müssen
bestimmt wird
die von den freunden der kantischen
philosophie ein zb von schmid als die
gesamte freiheit die ganze hand gehalten
diese freiheit von der er spricht
unabhängigkeit
praktisch fünf in einem kritischen
stimmen ein bestimmungsbuch das ist die
moralische freiheit freiheit hat das ist
die freiheit die dir eine praktische
vernunft besitzt nur sagt jetzt reinheit
wir haben als freie personen freie
individuen nicht nur die freiheit zu
morales guten zehn jahren auch eine
unmoralische freiheit können uns auch
gegen die forderung der sittengesetz
oder nach seiner terminologie des
uneigennützigen triebes bestimmen und
die freunde der kantischen philosophie
sagt ins reinhold die haben sich zu sehr
auf die praktische frage also nur auf
die freiheit zum quoten konzentrierte
freiheit der einparkhilfe und die haben
diese schattenseite oder die alternative
nicht genug berücksichtigt aus der
verwechslung sektor an und weitet er
zwar selbst tätig aber nichts weniger
als freien handlung der praktischen
vernunft die nichts als das gesetz das
sieht ein gesetz gibt mit den handlungen
des willens
denn nur dadurch als der reine handelt
dass er dieses gesetz feuer greift muss
nichts geringeres als die uhr möglich ja
der freiheit für alle und sinnlichen
abentung erfolgen sobald einmal
angenommen ist dass die freiheit des
rheingolds lediglich in der
selbsttätigkeit der praktischen steht so
muss man auch zugeben dass das unreine
wollen welches nicht durch praktische
unterricht ist keineswegs frei sein
wirklich hat alle der vorzüglichen
schriftsteller aus der kantischen schule
gegen kann zu beweisen versucht das bei
den unsittlichen handlungen nicht etwa
bloß der veranlassen
sondern auch die bestimmende grund des
wollens außer der person aufzusuchen und
der wille nur in der zeitlichen
handlungen allein frei sein
also sie können sich denken wir dass ist
von dem er spricht er ist der
vorzügliche schriftsteller
da kann der schule natürlich wieder
christian
schmid ja der hat gesagt bei den
unsittlichen handlungen als bei den
bösen handlungen ist der bestimmende
kunde des wollens also der die willkür
die iss außerhalb der person aussuchen
nehmens ein hindernis das ist ein
internist rein praktischen finden und
deswegen sind werden und in siegen
handlungen frei wo uns keine hindernisse
entgegen steht also er kritisiert die
kantischen denke also die schritte der
schule die freunde der kann schon
philosophie die hätten die reine praxis
fünft verwechselt mit der handlung des
bilanz und reinhold kritisiert dass
dabei die individuelle entscheidung zu
kurz kommt die entscheidung für oder
gegen das gesetz er ist eines nächste
zitat gigantischen beschriften haben den
bestimmten begriff der das logische
wesen des wirts enthält nur er ist
vorbereitet keineswegs schon geliefert
sie beschreiben will bald durch dieses
bald durch jenes merkmal das war
denselben jedes mal nach der rücksicht
in der von ihm geräte ist bestimmt genug
bezeichnet aber welche sind anderen
rücksicht liegen gebraucht neben mit
anderen dingen vermengen ganz äußerungen
von dem willen sollen seine absicht nach
immer nur eine gewisse bestimmung des
willens die mit anderen zum wesen des
eben gehört mir aber das lesen selbst
ausdrücken wenn er den willen bald
kausalität ist nun bald ein vermögen
nach äthiopien oder nach der vorstellung
der gesetze zu handeln weil ein vermögen
etwas gemäss eine idee hervorzubringen
nennt so ist es seine schuld nicht diese
redensarten die als bloße exposition von
ihm gebraucht völlig war sind dann
seinen schülern zur definitionen erhoben
und eben dadurch schlecht zu tun haben
werden
also was fällt hier auch reinhold möchte
jetzt kommt erstmal in schutz nehmen so
ist es seine schuld nicht kann selbst
sagt 30 hat jetzt keinen integrieren
fatalisten
vertreten weil er den willen und die
freiheit gar nicht richtig definiert hat
zum jahres vorbereitet hat er sagt auch
eine andere stelle sind los expositionen
also nur darlegungen aber noch keine
definition das ist die frage
ich bezweifele dass glaube kann
zumindest in der kritik der praktischen
und den schon sehr genau definiert
nämlich als reine praktische fahndung
jedenfalls versucht denn hier so ein
bisschen schutz erhalten und kritisiert
aber dennoch das dekantieren einerseits
1 kausalität der vernunft ein vermögen
nach prinzipien
also es gibt verschiedene definitionen
des willens bekannt das stimmt
sicherlich das heißt aber nicht dass es
dann ganz verschiedenes bedeutet
vielleicht hat hier kann nur
verschiedene aspekte des willst darlegen
wollen jedenfalls kritisiert reinheit
dass die nach kantischen denker sein
schüler oder freunde dass die diese
grund bestimmungen verfälscht haben und
dadurch eben zu sehr kontraktiven
ergebnissen oder paradoxen oder auch
ohne haltbaren theorien kamen wie eben
der intel gibt den fatalismus
jetzt kommt ein wichtiges zitat von
reinhold er sagt der eine will es sowohl
als der unreinen sind daher nichts
anders als die beiden gleich möglichen
handlungsweisen des freien willens beide
zusammengenommen gehören zur natur der
freiheit die ohne die eine von beiden
denn arztes sein aufhört das reine
wollen es nun darum frei weil es
äußerung des jähnigen vermögens ist von
dem es abhängt auch rein
er wolle der schon mal eine weile ist
freilich an die gries gesetz bestimmte
und der sturmreihe an die bild lust und
unlust gegen das gesetz bestimmt der
handlungsweise gebunden aber sowohl bei
dem ein als in anderen bindet die person
sich selbst an eine dieser
handlungsweisen die er beide gleiche
zeit
hier geht jetzt um die frage nach dem
rhein oder unreinen wollen kurz gesagt
auch nach dem guten und bösen handeln
reinhold betont gegen spielt das ist
gleich mögliche handlungsweisen als
aktionen wie der prinz werner d'inka
sibylle die spd abgeben sind des freien
willens der kann sich entscheiden fest
einen das andere und wenn er nur eine
wahl hat dann hört er auf frei zu sein
braucht beide optionen
das reine wollen ist nur deswegen fall
teilt sich wie auch anderswo wollen die
personen dann geändert
das heißt die person entscheidet am ende
wie sie will und das reine wollen ist
nicht frei als das unheil bewahrt worden
was das für eine welt ganz wichtig dass
klar aber keineswegs durch deutliche
begriffe unterstützt bewusstsein dieses
durch sich selbst bestimmen vermögens
hat im system mit derek wie die christen
wie die christen sind auch vertreter der
indifferenz freiheit also die von einem
gleichgewicht des willens ausgehen
diejenige spuren des richtigen begriff
ist von der freiheit angegeben die aus
mangel an bestimmten begriffen folgen
bringen vermögen des gemütes weder von
ihm selbst gehörig benutzt noch von
ihren gegnern verstanden wurde
offenbar wollten sie durch die von ihm
behauptete gleichgültigkeit des willens
gegen alle beweggründe und wo ich das so
genannte gleichgewicht kriterium in
welchem sich der werden rücksicht auf
die forderung zu holen als dass er nicht
am ende nichts als die unabhängigkeit
der selbstbestimmung von allen
objektiven gründen die willkürlichkeit
ist bei den maxim andeuten allein da sie
in ihren unbestimmte begriffe vom willen
keineswegs den seen anzugehen vermochten
in welchen die selbstbestimmung wollen
von der sinnlichkeit der fünft
unabhängig sind so mussten sie eine
solche unabhängigkeit des wildes teilens
wirklich behaupten teils behaupten
scheinen wirklich nicht stattfindet die
anderen sondern das bewusstsein
widerspricht ja diese
sogar den begriff des willens selbst
aufheben also er kritisiert jetzt hier
eine theorie der kreativsten das könnte
man auch die indifferenz freiheit nennen
die gehen von einer gleichgültigkeit
dass wir uns gegen alle weg und aus und
denn sie haben deswegen bestimmten
begriffen wieder
ja und das ist natürlich nicht gut weil
sie den begriff deswegen selbst aufheben
der wille ist nicht gleichgültig sondern
eben gerade entschieden
der wille ist ja der wille ist
willkürlich insofern er eben eine der
optionen auswählen
der grund dieser wahl der kommt jetzt
gleich zur sprache jetzt kann ich
nämlich von ihr aber warum wählt jetzt
der wille einmal so einmal so das musste
ein grund kleben und jetzt sagt ein
heute hier folgendes durch die
praktische vernunft bestimmten person
selbst aber unwillkürlich dem willens
ein gesetz durch die selbsttätigkeit in
köln gegen handeln sie diesen
gesetzesgemäß buckel zuwider
diese ist der einzige subjektive und
durch selbst bestimmen können jene die
branche gehörte gleich mit den
forderungen des betriebs nach vergnügen
zu den objektiven und an sich selbst
bloß veranlassen sind können das heißt
es kann daher nicht ohne ungereimtheit
nach dem objektiven außer der frei des
objekts gelegenen kunde freien und
eigentümlichen an kristens gefragt
werden diese frage würde ebenso viel
reisen als worin liegt die objektive
kommt durch welches das von objektiven
gründen unabhängig zu handeln bestimmt
wird
es lässt sich kein objektiven grund des
wollens denken denn nicht diesen lang
der freiheit zu tanken hätte die freie
hand ist da auch nichts weniger als
grundlos der grund ist die freiheit
selbst aber diese ist auch der letzte
denkbare kunden anklang
es ist die absolute die erste ursache
ihrer handlung welche sich nicht
weiterhin ausgehen lässt weil sie
wirklich von keiner anderen abhängt
fragen warum der freie wille sich auf
diese oder jene stimmt austragen warum
ist er frei von aussetzen eines von ihm
selbst bestimmten grundes heißen die ihm
seine freiheit zu sprechen reinhold gibt
jetzt hier eine antwort auf die thematik
des letzten starts des indifferent ismus
woher nimmt er will jetzt eine
bestimmtheit und er sagt die willkür ist
die selbsttätigkeit des willens das ist
ein durch sich selbst bestimmen kommt
alles es gibt keinen objektiven grund
sondern es ist immer ein subjektiver
grund und er sagt jetzt hier etwas
missverständliches die freihaltung ist
darum nichts weniger als grundlos damit
meint er jetzt nicht dass es keine
gründe gibt für die handlung sondern es
gibt kein grund außerhalb der freiheit
also es gibt nichts was der freien
handlung also etwas was außer ihr liegt
zugrunde liegt deswegen sagt er gleich
demnach dick und finance die freiheit
selbst sein selbst grund sie die reihe
ist ja so die erste große reise hängt
von keinem grund ab außer von mir selbst
als voraussetzt es bedürfe eines von ihm
selbst verschiedene gründe es heißt ihm
den willen seiner zeit abzusprechen
also freiheit ist selbst kommt der grund
in sich selbst habe so bestimmt er jetzt
die freiheit
zitat zur willkür
man hat gegen diesen begriff der
freiheit das logische gesetz zu reichen
grundes aufgerufen dem derselbe geradezu
widersprechen sollte allein der begriff
der freiheit widerspricht diesen
gesetzen nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als den 7 der begriff einer absoluten
ersten ursache welche sich jene gegner
der freiheit bei anderen gelegenheiten
wohl gar denken können widerspricht
historische gesetzt wurden keineswegs
für alles was da ist eine
die sind da ist ein verschiedene wasser
sonst würde das dasein gott ist ja
selbst jedes dasein von ewigkeit durch
jenes gesetz unmöglich science oder es
fordert das nicht ohne grund gedacht
die vernunft hat aber einen serien grund
die freiheit als einen absoluten ursache
zu denken nämlich dass sie durch welche
sich die handlung dieses vermögens als
eine tatsache ankündigt und den
gemeinden und gesunden verstand
berechtigt von ihrer wirklichkeit auf
ihre möglichkeit zu schließen jetzt
kommt hier wieder dieses problem ins
spiel was im ausgang von bereit jetzt
ersatz des zu erreichen kommen müssen
ist in die freiheit jetzt kein grund
also ihr dann widerspricht sie doch sagt
antizipiert jetzt reinhold den einwand
dass sie dem satzes zu erreichen kommt
es zu reden ist jetzt hier
wir sehen aber in angelegenheiten
anderen zusammenhängen dass zb dass
sarah gottes gott wird auch als eins
selbst grund bestanden dass es hier
offensichtlich akzeptiert wird von
vielen denken und ein weiterer punkt ist
das jetzt reinholz sagte dass es hier
gar nichts ist sehr um das unter
logische geht als vielmehr um das denken
sondern es fordert das nicht ohne grund
gedacht werde
das wurde das logische gesetz nach
reinhold nur das denken und dann hätte
man ja ein grund da nämlich den selbst
grund der freiheit
jedenfalls sagt er hier weiter die
freiheit als erstes denken nämlich das
selbstbewusstsein das ist auch noch ein
wichtiger grund
also er mit diesem einwand zu entgehen
der auch in der ganzen debatte immer
wieder im spiel
zum schluss noch ein zitat über das
grundvermögen der wein dann muss es auch
die philosophieren der von uns beraten
lassen
durch genaue entwicklung der
verschiedenen beim wollen beschäftigen
vermögen des gemütes zwar völlig
begreifen dass der mittel frei ist aber
nicht wie diese freiheit möglich ist sie
begreift aber auch selbst durch diese
entwicklung bringen sich dieses wie er
nicht begreifen lässt
es ergibt sich nämlich aus derselben
dass das vermögen der maximen oder der
willkürlichen vorschriften ein von der
praktischen vernunft sowohl als von dem
sinnlichen und durch theoretische
finanzprofi zierten ohne kirchen
bewegung vermögend ganz verschiedenes
mit beiden zusammenhang sich größen das
aber in rücksicht auf seine
eigentümliche form kommt ein
unabhängiges vermögen des gemütes einen
großen vermögens sei das vermögen der
praxis immer als die freiheit ist ein
grundvermögen da sich als ein solches
von keinem anderen vermögen ab leiden
und daher auch aus keinem anderen
begreifen und erklärt die frau des
wilkins daher um nicht begreiflich als
jedes andere grundvermögen des gemütes
als die ziemlich kite der verstand an
die vernunft die sich beim bewusstsein
nur durch ihre wirkung auf den fahrern
in ihren gründen aber insoferne
unbegreiflich sind als sie selbst den
letzten angeblichen kommt ihrer wirkung
nach außen gibt sich enthalten
hier ist ein bekanntes zitat ganz
prominent einer richtung freiheit der
maxime hat die freiheit ist ein
grundvermögen also ein grundvermögen sie
erhält den grund für sich selbst
so kann man verstehen grundvermögen das
nicht ganz verschieden verstehen ich
habe dafür argumentiert dass ein
vermögen der gründe ist also dass es
kaum geben der freiheit konnte abzuwägen
die natürlich aus einem selbst stammen
ein wichtiges die tat
und jetzt werden wir uns dem ende
ich bin auch ein zitat bringen und die
linken
die person kann sich nur insofern zu
wirklichen befriedigung oder nicht
befriedigung der forderung des eigenen
betriebes durch sich selbst bestimmen
sie hatten nur insofern willen als sie
durch dem eigenen zentralen forderungen
des eigenen nun eigene betrieb von den
forderung des eigennützigen und wilke
von den forderungen beider unabhängig
ist
diese unabhängigkeit stimmt besteht die
negative und der willkür und dem
vermögen sich für eine der beiden vorder
und selbstbestimmt die positive freiheit
das will die sich eben darum die
ankündigung bei der forderung im
bewusstsein die folglich nie ohne
selbstbestimmung für die gegen das
praktische gesetz oder ohne moralität
denken wer ist eigentlich die tür
willkommen strengsten sinne findet wie
schon der name andeutet niehaus er
willens haltung die sich in ihre
handlungsweisen selbst welt gekürt statt
also ja er sagt jetzt hier die person
befriedigt einträge oder sie befriedigt
das hatten wir schon gesehen da vor
und jetzt sagt das geht so
uneigennützigen trieb oder dem eigenen
zehen trete ohne eigennützige trieb der
ist das sieht ein gesetz kann tisch
gesprochen der eigenen ist müsste
eigentlich oder egoismus
wir haben immer die wahl zwischen beiden
trieben zuerst wurde dieser in der
zweifachen unabhängigkeit also die
willkür die freie person muss sich nicht
für das einige andere entscheiden
sie hat eine negative freiheit freiheit
von und sie hat aber auch eine positive
freiheit nämlich sie kann sich dafür
entscheiden
man weise davon frei ist negativen sinne
und hier bestimmt noch mal die willkür
wilke ist das wählen dass selbst wählen
dass der küren
sie kennen die kür sie kennen auch das
englische wort hughes das hängt alles
damit dass die wahrheit des lebens die
wahlen genauer gesagt des triebes für
dem wir uns konfrontiert sein
ja so viel zu reinholz sehr
interessanter files theorie die im
kontext dieser dem auto hervor sticht
und auch viele andere theorien
beeinflusst hat ich wünsche immer einen
teilnehmer wie den teilnehmern alles
gute und freue mich sie virtuell in der
nächsten sitzung wieder zu sehen